ok lets see where you end up on this
next orion and good grease with more how
disagrees with a htc so but i look site
democrats robbery blog impeachment
trial and album green team that is na
could help
the feed download from pint monotony and
love explain  a sorry sorry my mic
effigies i'm getting my software
reports story as a beginning the
impeachment en korey is not going to end
wit
donald trump be removed from the province
buyer republic and controls and therefore
they know that impeachment angry with
handle future newspaper of  i helping
now we've seen the whistleblower
complete
there is no question that other lang in
addition there the english and in peace
memorial donald trump is mine tonight at
defect murders
also in shape that the race must correct
must based on what i know  is a pitch
with input
the balance is how much you democrats
expo balance of from doing to the angry
birds your success loved ones do on
trump himself s the thickness and the mud  and
the target of assilex cc
presidential race with democrats arnhem
moving towards strategy
also narrow in the scope of the
impeachment angry
to be only about the campaign for a
fiasco well again idea is to investigate
anything the donald trump is dan other
the you everything in the  impeachment
angry because of sort of integration of
the investigation
i wish had to the next steps
more quickly that i wanted your abstraction
and then could their blood self die
lindern iphone or a pub or via
least forsyth inc is a private ball in
an app itself that  not only be part of
this investigation decors are democrats
ar that stuff unstable on those
individual house comedies
where the mini mini time the of the
public eye s part of the impeachment
gary is just new
completely free nancy pelosi are in the
measurement they just a real  talk about this
coat with clarity and understanding in
the eyes of the american people talking
about the great story whatever the
articles  opinions good moves
with arguments presidential should be
week in in grew other tanks opinion
if they decided to go forward with trine
2 beachfront
week in impeach for more than just great
but the increasing the just about
ukraine
alcides sd stunning mistake and
strategic blender bon 100 campers  and
understand media
democrats after in agreement about
impeach an abstraction
democrats to in agreement soil
teaching anomaly mens violations em in
europe pearls and the idea is again everything
democrats
nancy process and in your grimaud die
impeachment about grant him peace me
ingrowth about ukraine
they talked  sauna what is a few
mystics in her lilac the first mistake
is that the priests
democrat art actually unanimously en
agreement on so this is a majorie of
democrat in-house designer belts in the
same way de
de door was upon a few weeks ago
romantico where  a majority of the right
thing to be an agreement with star things
impeachment in corey i of the  fondness
for a thing what er atelier in
democrats der nar
in favor of the impeachment angry and
mentioned earlier in the show so als ik
word is when those people who is na
in favor of the idea that support for
this in korey is jonah name is
is  rank in it and false promises and
which the english die beasts decision
to be made so then we got the second
scribble the most important thing here is
the republic in want after some remove from and
via twitch and already in so and it also filing the
house
articles is a disaster with the hoi
also narrow in scope is moving so long
more quickly so that week it file
articles de winkies with journalism
decide what you may be evil is here
why republic in sargon to go to remove
from no matter what now you could  argue
wel has the democrats jewelry league and
groove s'posing from from doing any file
articles about peach met and republic in
stil download or remove him republic in
zwolle greeley baden in rotterdam and
trump and tony tony single  is the rank
calculation i think the platform and everything
are on think that is based in fact
the ukraine story is very reasonable in
the cupboard
sorry full impeachment in restarting
right now but i disagree of the
insole focus peak is there is chris
summer morning  the value with angry is
ik s'pose
witkamp es den ende weer u that is after 10 euros
so buy
jump for all your eyes and honda skyteam
from desk it strategy
he plays for democrats other donald
trump
heavily color that we have a democracy this
one thing  is the devastating to
drunk and and sapna
ping devastating to donald trump icy the
session process after a sphere it
the ukraine sing my love like double it
for the latest just be a part of a
process that includes financial times
abstraction him a fiasco there  so
much more and i'm on fire obama donor
of bing
incorrectly ran sms de gaiwan i for this
now once rising hope that this entire
in unison i will do anything to help
must donald trump
in november 201  0 change my mind if you
believe on bing
incorrect walked text thick 20 hours from you
guys i already
strategic mistakes big media